[Music]
the seafarer israeli global scholars
program
makes bets on young faculty just
starting out on their careers
and affords them opportunities that are
unparalleled
that allow you to catapult your ideas
as well as gain traction and communities
over an extended period of time the
seafarer australia global scholars
program afforded
me an ability to execute on some of the
vision that i had for my laboratory
in areas that were not necessarily easy
to get funded
it was really refreshing to be in a
virtual room
with a bunch of other scientists at my
stage of career
who are all unafraid to share where they
are succeeding but also where they are
failing
being able to interface with these
fantastic scientists from all around the
world not just here in the united states
but who came from
europe and asia to be at that meeting
was really fantastic
really expanded my global network in a
very concrete and tangible way
the cross-disciplinary nature of the
seafarers reality program
is very unique it affected the way i
think about
projects in lab and the research
direction that i'm taking the lab
we are not only microbiologists
immunologists
which is also two different fields in
biology but also anthropologists and
philosophers and
i really like the way we try to look for
principles in the fields and try to
crosstalk between them by joining the
cfar israeli global scholars program i
got to
form friendships with other scholars who
live in different countries and
continents we not only discuss
science but we also discuss life and
challenges that we all face as early
career academics
and even though my time in this program
is coming to an
end this friendship and bond that i have
formed with
other cfar israeli global scholars that
will that will remain
into the future